♪♪
[LAUGHTER]
GOOD SONG.
WELCOME BACK TO THE BIG SUNDAY
SHOW.
WE NOW KNOW HOW MUCH TWITTER AND
THE FBI WORKED TOGETHER.
MORE THAN 150 E-MAILS EXCHANGED
BETWEEN THE FBI AND THE FORMER
TRUST AND SAFETY HAD FOR TWITTER
BETWEEN JANUARY 2020 AND
NOVEMBER OF 2022 OH.
AT ONE POINT THE FBI SOCIAL
MEDIA SPECIALIZING TASK FORCE
WHICH BY THE WAY WAS CREATED
AFTER THE 2016 ELECTION, THAT
EXPANDED TO ABOUT 80 DIFFERENT
AGENTS PRIMARILY HUNTING DOWN
ELECTION MEDDLING.
NOW THE INCOMING HOUSE CHAIRMAN
SAYS THE FBI HAS MORE EVIDENCE
OF COMMUNICATIONS WITH TWITTER
AND OTHER MAINSTREAM MEDIA.
>> IT IS MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
THERE ARE SECRET FILES AT THE
FBI HAS OF THESE CONTACTS THEY
WERE HAVING WITH SOCIAL MEDIA
AND WITH MAINSTREAM MEDIA.
IT HAS BEEN OUR OBJECTIVE TO GET
A HOLD OF THOSE FILES TO SEE THE
EXTENT OF THIS SO THAT WE CAN
STOP IT.
THIS IS A CAMPAIGN BY THE FBI
THAT IS OUTSIDE OF THE BOUNDS OF
ANYTHING WE WOULD EXPECT THEM TO
DO AND CERTAINLY IS VERY
CONSTITUTIONALLY TROUBLING.
>> FINDING THE FBI'S INFLUENCE
ON TWITTER WAS MUCH MORE
SIGNIFICANT THAN FORMER GENERAL
COUNSEL JAMES BAKER.
MORE THAN ONE DOZEN AGENTS WERE
AMONG THE TOP RANKED AT TWITTER
BEFORE ELON MUSK EVER TOOK OVER.
AND, AT THE LEFT NOW PANICKING
THAT IT COULD LOSE CONTROL OVER
SOCIAL MEDIA.
A SENATOR WROTE A LETTER
DEMANDING FACEBOOK "RECOMMIT TO
CENSORING OPPOSING VIEWS OR FACE
THE CONSEQUENCES.
OKAY.
ACTUALLY, I WANT TO START WITH
YOU, RAYMOND.
I WANT TO PULL UP REAL QUICK
LATE THE NEW FOX NEWS OP-ED.
IF WE COULD JUST READ IT REALLY
QUICKLY.
SENSOR OR ELSE.
DEMOCRATIC LAWMAKERS WORN
FACEBOOK NOT TO BACKSLIDE ON
CENSORSHIP.
RAYMOND, WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF
THIS?
>> ADAM SCHIFF IS PART OF THIS.
THE MOVEMENT AMONG DEMOCRATS WHO
TRY TO CONVINCE OTHER SOCIAL
MEDIA COMPANIES AS TWITTER IS
UNDER SURVEILLANCE NOW BY THE
REPUBLICANS.
HE WANT THEM TO KEEP THE
SAFEGUARDS IN PLACE.
THIS IS ACTUALLY A PROTOCOL THAT
LIKE-MINDED IDEOLOGUES CREATED
AND NOW THEY WANT TO KEEP IN
PLACE.
YOU HAVE TO PROTECT AGAINST THIS
INFORMATION.
THIS IS FROM THE PERSON THAT
BROUGHT YOU THE RUSSIAN
COLLUSION HOAX THAT HUNTER'S
LAPTOP CAME FROM RUSSIA AND WAS
NOT CREDIBLE.
THESE PEOPLE MASTER IN THIS
INFORMATION, DISTORTING
INFORMATION.
IN THAT REALLY RUNS TO THE
POINT.
NO POLITICAL PARTY.
NOR LIBERALS AND DEMOCRATS
SHOULD CONTROL INFORMATION FLOW.
OUR GUARANTEE IN AMERICA, OUR
BACKSTOP IS A UNINFORMED
POPULIST.
WHEN YOU DISTORT THE INFORMATION
THEY ARE GETTING, YOU ARE
DISTORTING THE OUTCOME.
WE MUST GUARD AGAINST THAT.
IT IS THE LAST FRONTIER.
WHAT THE FOUNDERS PUT IN PLACE
THAT INFORMATION HAD TO BE FREE.
THAT IS WHY THEY ENSHRINED IT IN
THE CONSTITUTION.
AT THIS UNDERMINES THAT
CONSTITUTIONAL PROTECTION.
>> YOU HAD AN INTERESTING
CONVERSATION.
WHAT WAS SOME OF THE INSIGHT
THAT YOU GOT.
>> REMEMBER, ALL WE HEARD WAS
RUSSIA, RUSSIA, RUSSIA.
IT REALLY JUST TURNED OUT TO BE
A MANUFACTURED HIT JOB.
NOW WE ARE LEARNING OF THE
PRETEXT TO SPY ON AMERICANS AND
TRY TO RIG THE 2020 ELECTION.
I ASKED BECAUSE WITH GARLAND
THEY WILL MEET RESISTANCE AT THE
DOJ AND THE FBI PROBABLY WILL
NOT PLAY BALL AS THEY ISSUE
SUBPOENAS.
HE SAID THAT THEIR FOCUS WILL BE
LOOKING AT PRIVATE BUSINESSES,
PRIVATE SECTOR PEOPLE.
HAVING MORE SUCCESS THEY ARE
TRYING TO GET MORE INFORMATION.
THEY WILL NOT GET THE SAME
ASSIST WITH STEVE BANNON LOOKING
OUT FOR MONTHS IN JAIL FOR
CONTEMPT DID CONGRESS CHARGES.
HE SAYS THAT THEY WILL BE
LOOKING AT PRIVATE SECTORS.
I WOULD ASSUME THAT ALL OF THESE
GUYS WILL BE ON THE RECEIVING
END OF THE SUBPOENAS.
>> REPUBLICANS WILL HEAD AND,
OBVIOUSLY, WITH THE MAJORITY AND
THEY WILL DIG, DIG, DIG.
WHO DO YOU THINK PEOPLE WILL
LISTEN TO?
>> YOU JUST ASSUME THAT THAT IS
HOW THINGS ARE.
IN A CONGRESSMAN OUT THERE HAS A
SCANDAL, MOST AMERICANS WILL
SAY, YEAH, THAT IS ABOUT WHAT WE
EXPECT.
REPUBLICANS REALLY NEED TO PLAN
AND HAVE A STRATEGY AND
UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY WILL
INVESTIGATE AND WHY WHAT THEY
CAN GET OUT OF IT TO EITHER SWAY
THE VOTE OR SHOW THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE WHY IT'S IMPORTANT TO
PUSH BACK ON THESE THINGS.
THE FBI CAN JUST SIT THERE AND
SAY THEY HAD THIS UNDER THE
GUISE OF NATIONAL SECURITY,
ELECTION INTEGRITY.
THEY CAN USE THE BUZZWORDS.
THIS IDEA THAT THIS IS NOT
PARTISAN IN ANY WAY, THAT IS ALL
THERE TO MAKE SURE THAT RUSSIA
AND CHINA ARE NOT COLLUDING.
IT IS LEFT ON THE REPUBLICANS TO
FIND SPECIFIC E-MAILS.
SPECIFIC ACTIONS, SPECIFIC
DOCUMENTED ORGANIZATIONS.
EVEN IF SOMEBODY TURNS ON YOU,
YOU DO NOT KNOW WHAT THEY ARE
TELLING THE TRUTH.
I WANT THEM TO GO PLACES THAT
THEY CAN HAVE AN EFFECT AND
CHANGE HOW THINGS ARE DONE
RATHER THAN GALVANIZE, YOU KNOW,
THE DEEP STATE WHERE THE
DEMOCRAT IS AGAINST US.
>> THAT IS MY QUESTION.
WHAT WILL THIS GET DONE.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, WHEN YOU
HOLD THE HEARINGS AND YOU MAKE
THE HEADLINES, WHAT CHANGES?
>> HOPEFULLY, IT RAISES AMERICAN
AWARENESS.
THE FACT THAT THEIR INFORMATION
HAS BEEN CONTROLLED.
IT IS CONTROLLING THE PIPE.
THAT IS REALLY WHAT IS AT PLAY
HERE.
I THINK THAT WHEN YOU FIND OUT
THAT THE FBI AND STATE
GOVERNMENTS USED A BACKDOOR
COMPLAINT DESK AT TWITTER CALLED
TELEPORTER TO SNITCH OUT PEOPLE
IT DID NOT LIKE, IDEOLOGUES THEY
DID NOT LIKE, PEOPLE COMING FROM
THE CONSERVATOR SIDE AND JOKES
MADE ON TWITTER, THAT THAT
BECAME THE MARCHING ORDERS FOR
TWITTER TO CENSOR CONTENT AND
WHAT IT OPEN THE DOOR TO HIS IT
IS NOT JUST TWITTER.
IT IS FACEBOOK, IT IS YOU TWO.
ALL OF THESE SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS.
NOW YOU HAVE A POLITICAL WAR
GOING ON.
WE NEED TO LIBERATE THESE
PLATFORMS.
LET FREE SPEECH RAIN.
THE DEMOCRAT SPEECH THEY KNOW WE
PUT THESE PROTOCOLS IN PLACE AND
YOU WILL KEEP THEM THERE.
WE WILL SEE WHO WINS, BUT THAT
IS A POLITICAL STRUGGLE.
UP TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE NOW.
>> I THOUGHT TWITTER WAS GOING
TO DISAPPEAR LIKE FIVE YEARS
AGO.
NOBODY CARED ABOUT IT.
>> FBI LAWYER JAMES BAKER GOING
TO TWITTER FIVE MONTHS BEFORE
THE 2020 ELECTION